each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
goes on assistant professor there and
his research bridges the area of systems
and programming languages for his PhD
dissertation he designed and implemented
a general language based approach for
dynamically upgrading running software
and that dissertation won the 2002 ACM
sigplan doctoral dissertation award so
we're going to hear now I guess about
what's what's new in dynamically
updating software so floors yours thank
you thanks Paul all right thanks for
having me so the work that I'm going to
talk about today I actually after I
finished my dissertation I got sort of
sick of the topic and I moved away into
other things for a while but I've been
working with a bunch of other people who
were interested in the topic and it's
kind of rekindled my interest so the
work I'm going to talk about today is
stuff we've been doing over the past
couple years and exploring how to make
the ideas that I initially explored as
part of my dissertation more practical
for for real programs well I should say
my collaborators are Gareth's toil Gavin
Biermann and Peter school they're all at
Cambridge iulian am too who is my
student at Maryland and then Manuel
Oriole who was a postdoc and he's now at
in Zurich I think this is jumping ahead
there we go
okay so what is dynamic software
updating well dynamic software updating
is the process of updating a running
program with new code and data and the
idea is that I want to preserve the
state and processing on my program while
nonetheless fixing bugs are adding new
features things like that and this is a
this process it's critical for non-stop
applications that can't afford to be
taken down but obviously still have bugs
and still need to be to have new
features and it's convenient for other
systems that may not be thought of as
non-stop like your operating system it
might be nice to patch your OS and then
just let it keep going rather than
having to reboot it so here's a sort of
a visualization of the software updating
process so on the Left we have a whole
bunch of source files that make up some
application and at the bottom here we
visualize the the running system so the
box is the program and this little
rectangle here is the state of the box
so it might be caches or current
connection state if it's a server or
something like that so we start with the
existing source and then modify the
program as we need to so we say we want
to fix a bug or add any feature so we
change all of those files then we're
going to compile and test the program
just as we always did we have our new
version we run our tests we don't make
sure that it works and now what you
might do in a typical situation is shut
down the old program and start up the
new one instead what we're going to do
is we're going to develop dynamic
patches based on the changed files and
then we're going to apply those patches
to the running system and the idea is
that the state of the existing system is
going to be preserved while the new
features and bug fixes and so on have
will be able to take place so the
advantage of this approach to software
updating is that it's general-purpose
basically it will work on arbitrary
application state whatever state might
be as part of the application you didn't
have to anticipate in advance what stuff
you might want to preserve between
software upgrades so this is in contrast
to the load balancing approach which is
typical for say web servers or other
sort of stateless servers where what you
do is you assume that all the state that
matters is often a database or a file
system somewhere and that way it's
always safe to kill an application as
long as it's not processing any
transactions and you can start up the
new version so while that approach works
great and you should certainly use it
when it may
sense it's nice to be able to have the
option of being able to deal with
arbitrary state that you might want to
preserve and not stuff you necessarily
anticipated that you needed the other
benefit of this approach is that you
don't need redundant hardware would be
hard to use the load balancing approach
to upgrade your OS and with this
approach you don't need that so the
challenge is then with software updating
our first of all flexibility I want to
be able to have a system in which the
changes I make to my source code as I
showed you before or ones that I can
make happen online I don't want to be
limited in the sort of changes i can
make online and therefore hamper the way
that my software evolves at the same
time I want safety I don't want to make
it so that if i change my program and
update it online it crashes because that
would sort of defeat the point of it
being nonstop and at the same time I
want to make things easier to use I
don't want to have to create really odd
application architectures and someone I
want to use architectures I'm familiar
with and I don't have to change the
application a lot even within that
architecture to support updating
moreover for each patch that process of
developing the dynamic patches it would
be great to not have to put too much
work on the programmer to make all of
that happen so these are these are the
lofty challenges and when I'm going to
talk about today's our progress towards
reaching these challenges I'm certainly
not going to claim that we we hit them
all dead on so what I'll talk about is
first of all our compiler for dynamic
updates so what we do is we compile the
program to be updateable and to generate
these patches and so i'll talk to you
about that compiler and the the runtime
mechanisms that we use for updating then
i'm going to talk to you about some
analyses that we have developed to try
to ensure type safety it's not
correctness but it's it's a step and in
particular I'm going to show you how a
badly timed update could violate type
safety in two ways either by changing a
type representation or changing a
function prototype or by having
abstraction violating casts and aliases
at certain points in the program and
I'll show you how the analysis can
detect these and therefore prevent
updates at bad times and then finally
I'll talk to you about how we've used
our implementation to dynamically update
a couple of programs and tell you about
our experience with it so far and what
we want to do next
okay so the first question then is let's
turn to flexibility if we want to figure
out how we want to update programs
online we need to figure out how
programs change so that we know what
features we need to support so what we
did was we did a little study by writing
a tool that would amount allowed us to
compare different versions of a sea
program to figure out well how did those
programs change in terms of their type
structure how often did I add function
definitions how often did the function
definitions change their type how often
did type representations change things
like that and we ran it on a bunch of
different applications and what we found
is probably somewhat intuitive first of
all software tends to grow not shrink so
many functions are added over time in
addition existing functions change
relatively frequently that is either to
fix bugs or to call the new versions of
the functions that were added or to
restructure the way that they work type
signatures definitely change over time
it's not the case that the type
structure of your program that this
function always has the same number of
arguments or that they're always the
same types less often typedef sand
structs change more frequently
prototypes change and very rarely did we
find that the types of global variables
change the most common case was the size
of an array might grow for a global
variable meaning that its storage
allocation had to be different but
otherwise it was very rare that a global
variable would change so given all of
this what we decided was that in order
to support the most flexible form of
software updating we needed to be able
to support all of these changes we need
to be able to replace add and delete
definitions at runtime and these could
be functions or global variables and the
functions that we update should be able
to have different types how did we
gather that data so we wrote a simple a
simple tool that did a syntactic
comparison of the two programs basically
would parse in the two abstract syntax
trees and then would go and look to see
for new definitions or ones that had
chained that were the same but might
have had different types and and so on I
think the only thing that was really
interesting about this tool was that it
did have some support for worrying about
renaming that it was certainly the case
that you might rename your functions and
our tool would then you would you didn't
want the tool to misreport in addition
in a deletion as opposed to a renaming
so we did handle that situation we have
a little workshop paper about it I can
talk to
after if you want okay so we want to be
able to change functions of global
variables functions should be able to
change types and we also need to be able
to change type definitions and change
the representations want to be able to
do this we need to define an abstraction
called a type transformer function that
can be run at run time to change
existing values that have the old
representations that they can be
converted to have the new representation
instead so this is used by our runtime
system to upgrade the data of the
program as it changes type so this is an
overview of the compilation process so
here in the in the upper left we have
the initial version of the program
version 0 C and we pass it into our
analysis and compiler AC and it
generates the new program or the initial
program which we can then deploy and
start running in addition it's going to
develop it's going to output some data
about the types and versions of the
functions in the program and as the
program changes over time this version
data is going to evolve so that we
always know the analysis always knows
what the current types are for things
that are running in the program so at
some point a new version of the program
becomes available so that's version 1 C
and we take the two versions pass them
to our patch generator which figures out
what the differences are between the two
versions and it generates a p1 see a
patch which we then compile and then
apply to the running program and this is
basically just a shared library that has
been compiled in such a way that when
you apply the shared library that it
will upgrade the program so that it's
now the new version and we just continue
this process onward until we get to the
end I should say that this process with
the patch generator here is not entirely
automatic that the programmer will have
to change parts of this patch you know
for example while we can do a basic job
of automatically generating type
transform of functions by doing a
syntactic comparison of types and things
like that we're obviously not going to
automatically figure out how to change a
list to a tree so the programmer is
going to have to come in and write some
of that stuff but the idea of the patch
generator is to get as much of the grunt
work out of the way as possible Pokemon
plans in an environment
and it makes sense when you make the
changes perhaps to assume more things
about them and environment disable the
user to run some applications when you
will do the process of generating the
patches anything like that do you do it
or do you assume that the environment is
the same let's see I'm not sure I
entirely understand your question but so
are you saying that because the program
is running in a certain environment I
might be able to change the way that I
develop a patch for it and you can post
a message to the user I'm now going to
fix it back please don't plan these
applications now so we don't we don't
make it we don't know that that would
make it easier on ourselves so we don't
do that why not do make it easy on me no
well okay so so I I agree that that if
we were faced with a circumstance in
which the only way to do an update would
be to do as you say then I agree to use
whatever means necessary but I the goal
is more how much can we make this
process easy to use right we want to
make it easier on the user so that they
don't notice the fact that things are
being updated
completely that's right so it may be
that in a lot of fan it could well be
that in practice you may need to do
exactly as you suggested so far in our
experience we haven't needed to do that
okay yeah so so essentially so you
haven't ever had to sort of disable
certain features or I mean in some sense
you do you have a problem of like
getting to a consistent state like there
might be intermediate states and you
might want the application to have quest
like if it's a GUI yes it's doing some
processing and you really don't want the
modal dialog to be up probably not doing
real things but but you know is there a
ninja you know you're exactly right so
so the second part of the talk is about
this timing issue yeah and and that's
exactly right you need to make it so
that to avoid certain problems that you
time your updates so as not to complete
with so that the state is basically
quite as soon as you say and for server
applications which are the things that
we've been focused on it's very easy to
find these quiescent points so given
that that's the case the user doesn't
notice any change we're able to make the
updates that happen pretty fast and the
user doesn't notice it may well be that
if you move to other domains that that
wouldn't be true ok so to to make this
work we have a our compiler is going to
compile the initial program and the
patch programs in order to allow them to
be updated in particular we need to be
able to update functions so we need a
way of making it so that when I load my
patch in that the new version starts
getting used rather than the old version
and then we also need to be able to
update type representations so that when
some code accesses values of a certain
type that they'll now get values of the
new type rather than the old type so we
do this basically every problem in
computer science can be solved with the
level of indirection so we add some
indirection the first of all the most
straightforward functioning direction
the compiler has an indirection between
each collar and the function and this
creates an invariant which is useful for
our safety analysis that every time you
call a function it's always going to be
to the most recent version and the
second level of indirection is what we
call type wrapping and basically what
happens there is we write little
accessor functions for accessing values
of the names type whether a struct type
or a type
definition and that way what happens is
whenever the program goes to access the
value of that type the accessor function
checks whether the value is of the most
recent version and if it is not it will
run the type transformer to bring it up
to date and then is the execution is
able to continue yep is there a reason
that you can't solve the first problem
using information that's already there
for the linker you could you could so
yes there are lots of optimizations that
you could perform that you could
drastically reduce the number of
function and directions and in some
sense this is really for expedience you
could even you could even do you know
binary rewriting to rewrite the call
sites to call to other places if you
wanted to to be honest we thought we
would have to do that but the
performance numbers have shown at least
for i/o bound applications it just
doesn't really it's not worth it might
as well not bother given that you're
kind of lazily rewriting these types at
run time are you having to add a level
of tagging or something to figure out
where you're at yes they're each each
type is and I'll show you how the
compilation works but each type is
tagged with a version field and the
accessor functions to look at the
version field and then transform it and
update the version
okay so here's a little example that
we'll use to show how the compilation
works so there's a struct definition t
that has two fields and there's a
function food that just takes a pointer
to an integer and then dereferences the
pointer and finally there's a function
call that takes that stack allocates
function the struct E and then it calls
it it passes it's a pointer to its X
argument to foo which is then
dereferenced okay so first I'll show you
how we do the type wrapping stuff so the
first thing we need to do is we need to
distinguish between the concrete what we
call the concrete and the abstract
versions of the types so the concrete
version is the sort of actual definition
that the program expects to use and the
abstract version is the one that has
this tag in it that tells us what the
actual version is so the first thing
that we do is we append we rewrite the
concrete version to have a version
number after it so that's the very top
line there when we take the actual type
and make it the concrete version and
then we define this abstract version
which has a version field and then has
the concrete version as part of it along
with some extra slop to allow the type
to grow over time I'll talk about that a
little bit more in a minute then we
define this accessor function here which
is going to take the abstract type a
pointer to it and return a pointer to
the concrete type and the first thing
that it does is it calls this transform
function that's going to check the
version field of the type and if the
version is not the current version it
will run the succession of type
transformers until it brings the type up
to date to bring the value up today and
then finally it returns a pointer back
to the value so the other way that we
could have done this in the other
perhaps obvious way to do it is to add a
level of indirection instead to the
abstract type instead of using the slop
space and in that case the process is
pretty much the same and we just return
this abstract this this pointer instead
so we decided not to do that because it
basically this made things more
complicated in particular now whenever
you do flat copies of structures you're
going to be copying it by reference
rather than copying it value value and
so you would break the semantics of the
program which would mean that your
compiler would have to notice whenever
you're doing a structure copy to be able
to actually copy the contents of the
structure and of course in see it's not
just that you're ever going to do an
assignment you might do mem copy
and things like that so it would cause
us to worry more in the compiler about
dealing with this this problem i see so
here you actually have the struct under
underscore underscore underscore teen on
data in the in law so you where is in
the next slide you actually have a level
of interaction that's correct so that
the the other drawback of this approach
is that you also need to worry about
memory management that is before when we
had a struct that was stack allocated
and we now have this abstract version
it's still stack allocated when the
stack frame goes away the whole thing is
cleaned up and it's gone or as in this
case we need to do some additional
allocation that has to be off somewhere
else which means that if it was supposed
to be stack allocated we need to insert
code to make it go away now we could do
something like a region allocator to
make this happen and probably we will
because then of course the main benefit
of this approach is that there is no
limit to how big a type can grow whereas
in this approach you have the slop space
that you pre-allocated that is going to
constrain how big your type can ever get
and the other problem is this is going
to throw off your cash in a big way it's
going to make it so that all this stuff
that you used to have maybe right next
to each other inside of an array is now
you know much more spread apart and we
have definitely seen that this is a
performance can be a performance problem
whereas when you add the level of
indirection it's easy to make all of the
things that you indirectly point2 all
pack together again so I think
ultimately again this is the this was
the more expedient choice and allowed us
to experiment with the process of
updating and I think ultimately when we
start to worry more about performance
will consider these other approaches the
getting too big get over over growing
the slot Oh what happens if you're
running your program and it gets too big
well that yeah you may use up all that
space or you get you yes so then yet the
compiler will say whoops your type grew
beyond the pre-allocated slop I don't
know
okay so you basically aren't allowed to
do yeah you know which is why this is
not the the right long-term approach I
mean the other attitude is that sort of
the way that I look at this is that this
technique of dynamic software updating
really you want to do it to prolong the
life of your application without
shutting it down not to actually make it
run indefinitely because you're going to
want to upgrade your hardware there's
all sorts of reasons that you're gonna
want to shut it down anyway so in some
sense what we really want to do is make
it so that you can run your program for
a year or two years or three years and I
think it is feasible to guess the right
amount of slop in advance to be able to
allow you to do that as opposed to run
forever but even so it seems more
elegant to use the interaction approach
but we'll just have to see how that goes
so C is your target rather than
something like
safety guarantees all we should have
done is we should have done it in
cyclone safe version of C so the reason
we didn't do it in Java or in ml or
functional language a type-safe language
was that basically well first of all
objects and closures add complication to
the interface for updating that is
there's lots of sort of implicit state
that you have to deal with when you're
writing your type transformers and we
hadn't worked out the fear a for dealing
with those things and so it seemed more
expedient to apply the theory that we
had worked out to a language that could
support it which was an imperative
language so then we went with C rather
than a safe see like language because
there are real applications that we can
try to update on the other hand it's not
so hard to port a see application to a
cyclone application cyclone is a
language that I also do work on that is
like sea but is type safe and makes
things a lot simpler and I think it
would have made made our lives much
better in many ways so it might have
been the wrong choice to go with C but
at least it gives us a way to try with
real applications I think that's the
main motivation was what guarantees do
you make when the application
balls
Oboro miss you know cast bad casts
so we don't make very many guarantees
our safety analysis is conservative in
dealing with casts and so on in terms of
how you might be able to update things
it is I don't believe it is not
conservative about buffer overruns so we
certainly would definitely wouldn't be
able to deal with that the only thing I
can say about that is you you could
easily imagine using CQ word or
something similar to pre pass to
eliminate those problems CLE masks buzz
that's what I was thinking
because you have the set off that's true
you're gonna change your stack layout so
quickly could pass but that's certainly
not making a guarantee no no no no no I
was actually wondering about
preservation in subsets like third
rather than rather than correctness
preservation yeah I'm sure I'm sure that
we are not deserving or at least to
creating the same semantics under which
above might manifest would it be
possible to keep a separate table that
maps the address is obstructed to their
versions so you can use the same LAN and
you could so does the thing I did in my
thesis was 22 actually not have a
different representation force trucks
but instead made it so that you had to
transform all of the data and update
time rather than a sort of lazy approach
which implied that you need to be able
to find it all and so my thesis what I
said was what it only is allowed to be
global variables and then you always can
find on so the other approach would be
to do as you say which is to keep some
map off to the side where I can have
pointers to all of these things and
there are some other projects that do
that but that that adds its own sets of
overheads and it also can be hard in a
language like C to figure out all the
places that you've allocated you know a
character buffer and then turned it into
one of these struts later on whereas
with the lazy approach you don't have
that problem because the only time you
care about what the type is when you're
about to use it and the casts and so on
we can track up until that point so
however as it turns out the updating
that we've done in practice often times
i found that lot most of the data that
you update tends to be global data
anyway that is there is some data that
is on the stack that is convenient to be
able to update but lots of the time its
global data so what I'm thinking now is
probably the right approach is to do
some kind of hybrid because it's often
very easy to find what data is going
likely to be stack allocated for a long
time and what data is start school obel
is always going to be global and so you
can reduce the number of types that you
need to compile in this way to be only
the ones that you deal with on the stack
and not everywhere and that makes it a
little bit makes it a little bit easier
to deal with because some of the
problems with the indirection approach
you know
wouldn't be on such a grand scale they
would only be occurring in a few places
and you could imagine tweaking your
program in those few places to have them
not be a problem but I'm completely
speculating here I have to we have to
get more experience to figure that out
ok so then here's a quick example for
how we would access the types so in that
call function now the initialization of
the struct T is going to be to include
the version field 0 and then have the
data as 12 and then the access of TX
inside the call to foo is going to be
through this con funk shun so the con
function will take the address of tea
and then it will pull out its X field
from the the concrete type that it gets
back before passing it to food ok so
here's functioning direction here's the
function foo that is called from the
call function and we want to make it so
that if at some point we update foo that
call is now going to call the new
version rather than the old version so
we need to add a level of indirection so
the first thing we do is we add do the
similar thing that we did for types we
add a version number to the concrete
definitions of the functions and then we
add some information about the function
at the top here and I've just showed the
the indirection point or the f pointer
to make it so that whenever I call food
down here at the bottom I'm always going
to go through this function pointer and
basically an update is then it going to
just change the f pointer pointer to
point to the new version rather than the
old version so that's all pretty
straightforward oh I didn't show it you
don't actually need to store a version
for the function only unless you were
going to do some kind of introspection
later on because you know that it update
Tony I'm just going to change all of the
functions to be the newest version so
it's only in sort of the version data
that we keep track of what the actual
version number is
in the first case you can have only 24
32 versions of variables or functions
and in the were stationed at one generic
one I mean size of it is tell you to
verify how you can go from zero to the
fourth minus two minus one end and then
count back to zero right so I'll appeal
back to my we only want to keep our
program running for three years not four
three you know many many more years in
that and functions don't change that
many times over that should I mean it's
probably overkill to have an int for the
version for the first or even about 32
bits because I mean I think in programs
that we've looked at over three year
spans things changed no more than maybe
four or five times when you're sort of
that store of the function data
structure it'll it'll work out the same
way so the what we do so won't work out
the same way so what we do is we write a
little wrapper function for that
function so the wherever we have a
function pointer that we would have
stored in there we create a placeholder
for the function pointer and inside of
the function the placeholder is a call
to that actual function via the function
pointer so then the placeholder address
never changes but what the placeholder
function calls continues to change as
the function is updated but how do you
know if you update function foo
which place holders actually contain
food right you don't care because
so if i have if i have foo here and i
have some data structure well so then
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna I'm gonna
do foo rap which is going to call food
within it and poo rap is not updatable
it's just a little wrapper function for
this guy so then if I have a data
structure that refers to in my source
program refers to foo in the compiled
program that will refer to foo rack
directly and then when sue is updated
foo rack will automatically call the
newest version Ron phone chats correct
and that's where it gets up there and
this is important and at least it in
your did updating Apache because
sometimes people do comparisons of the
address of a function and this way the
address will never change so that works
out nicely from that point you to what
happens in food education changes well
that's a that's that's the next second
part of the talk the answer is we still
change it inside the function pointer
there but we guarantee via analysis that
you'll never call it at the wrong time
but but you said the wrapper is never
updated so it will have the wrong
the rapper the middle rapper you just
wrote on the board that's right but you
have to think about so if i had this
data structure in the old program that
expected the food to be the old type
then oh I see what you're saying you're
saying because this function was
compiled so that the super nothing okay
good
you should check the flow level I guess
we should I guess we have to update the
food wrapper than to that defeats the
point I'm to David know why the pointers
just apply the function where is just a
pointer so oh you're right it doesn't
matter right this is I take it back this
is not actually a function this is
really just an address with the you know
that you that you call and this is not
really a call to jump so the point isn't
when I call the function at the new type
I'll have prepared the stack in the
correct way and then when i call this
function it's just going to jump to the
right function which expects the sack to
be in that that correct form so it
doesn't actually matter what the rapids
so does it doesn't actually have the
code that you're showing there its inlet
assembly no no I said yes rights in one
separate forgot
okay so another interesting case is
updating code that's on the stack so I'm
I'm falling behind so I'm going to race
through this but the basically the
problem is that if you have a program
that has a long-running loop or say an
infinitely and it turns out that in
later a later version of the function
that loop changes you're never going to
notice the update because the only way
that we ever notice updates is by
calling a function so what we do to
solve this problem is we sort of do the
opposite of closure conversion we make
it so that you can pull out a loop
that's in a function or any block of
code for that matter and turn it into a
function so that that way you know we
can notice notice that the updates so
basically the idea is that we're going
to extract the loop body out into a
function and the argument to the
function is the loop state when that's
going to be all the parameters and local
variables in the host function that
we're available to the loop will take
the addresses of those things and we'll
pass it at the function on each
iteration another part of the loops tape
is the actual return value of the host
function in case the loop were to return
and then the loop actions are just going
to be return codes that are handled in
the host and the cool thing about all of
this is it's just a pre past
transformation that we do on the source
program and then all of our existing
mechanisms work the past generation is
going to notice that the extracted loop
functions changed the loop states might
have changed and so you're gonna have to
write a type transformer for the loop
States and it all works out beautifully
that way and it turns out that we can
also use it for arbitrary code s by
doing this little transformation and
that's important for code that you
return to so here's a here's this ftp
server that we've been playing with
updating and it has two loops well it
has two places where we're going to use
this transformation so the way that the
program is set up it's a you can either
run it as a standalone program in which
case it's going to have a listen socket
and it's going to accept connections and
spawn them off to handle ftp requests or
you can run it as part of i net D where
I net D is going to accept the
connection and then it's going to call
your FTP program directly with the file
the Scriptures redirected to the correct
sockets so if you're running it in
regular mode you're going to skip this
call to standalone main and you're just
going to handle the connection in Maine
but if you're running it in standalone
mode where you're going to go over to
this function continuously accept
connections and then
turn back to main to handle the
connection so this is a little bit weird
if you want to be able to do updates
within this loop because then you have
to return back to this loop and then
execute this code which might be the new
version rather than the old version but
this code is you know the return address
is already on the stack so you need some
way to take this code and extract it out
as as well so that you can get to the
newest version so basically the what we
do is we just say well extract this loop
out so that way each iteration of the
loop is going to be to the new version
and extract this code out so that when
this code returns to it you're going to
get to the new version and this is a
piece of cake for the programmer I mean
basically you just label the loop and
say extract these loops and then the
compiler does the rest and yeah it's an
its work like a charm okay so that's the
runtime mechanisms that we use now I'm
going to talk about the safety analysis
that we use to be able to make sure that
we don't update things at a bad time and
basically the intuition with bad timing
is that look as an example say that
we've updated a type T so that its
representation has changed but we have
some existing code that expects the old
representation and it's just about to be
executed at the time that you change the
type representation you might end up
then passing code with a new
representation to old code that expected
the old representation and this all
depends on when the update took place so
here's a here's an example to try to
illustrate this a bit so here we have
our version that we saw before and now
let's say we update the type T so that
we make the the first feel a pointer
rather than an inline int so now let's
start running our program so the top is
the current type the thing in blue is
what type we will update to so we start
running here and we allocate the strep t
just not working anymore now we're going
to call the function foo and let's say
that we go ahead and do the update now
so we're going to change the
representation to be something else so
the first thing that's going to happen
is we're going to run the type
transformer when we go to access the X
field of T by using that con funk shun
and let's say that what that does is it
just allocate some space and throws the
one field into it okay now we're going
to go ahead and continue on and call oh
and we're going to take the address of
that field before calling foo so now
we'll call foo and foo is going to try
to dereference this pointer and fill in
that spot with one which you know now we
have a pretty serious type error because
now the first field which was supposed
to be a pointer is an integer instead so
what happened well even though the new
program was correct on its own the old
version of call was active at the time
of the update and it expected the old
representation and as it used it
concretely and a similar situation is
going to occur whenever you change the
types of functions or global variables
if I do an update to change the type of
a function at a point in some old code
that's just about to call that function
it's going to call the wrong version or
it's going to call with the wrong types
so what we need to do is find a way to
prevent this situation and we we do it
with analysis but let me tell you some
other ways that you might do it so one
approach would be four values that
change type you could just copy all of
the values from the old code to the new
code and have them and transform them
when you copy them and you could hope
that all those old values never get used
anymore and if they do they'll at least
be type correct but of course the
problem will be that the old code would
then operate on stale data you'll you'll
be updating two different versions of
the same data and that's probably not
what you want another solution is to
allow the situation to take place but to
also provide a backward of type
transformer so that whenever old codes
these new values it can convert them
backwards into old values again and you
can imagine the same thing for functions
whenever an old bit of a program wants
to call a new function you'll introduce
a little stub in between the two that
will be able to map the types but this
is something that we that other people
have explored and we've explored a
little bit and it just seems very hard
to reason about
that is in general it's a much cleaner
model to imagine that all your code
always is rolling forward but you always
know that whenever I call a function is
to the newest version and everything is
up to date and I don't need to worry
about what's going to happen if i
convert a value forward and they convert
it back and then forward and back is
it's going to do something weird so a
third approach is just a disallow active
updates to active code just don't allow
us to change the program when that call
function was active because the call
function had been changed but the
problem here is that your updates become
less available because you can't deal
with long-running loops and we
definitely found that it's critical to
be able to support long-running loops
which is why we did this loop
abstraction thing extraction thing so
what we do is we do a safety analysis
and we observe that these conte
functions give you a way to identify
where a type is used concretely and
these basically create constraints on
where updates are allowed to happen that
is we can dynamically dynamically
prevent updates that could lead to old
code concretely using a transform value
so we'll do this analysis at compile
time and be able to figure out well if
you were to perform an update here here
are all of the types that you shouldn't
be allowed to update at this update
point in order to not violate this
property and you can do the same thing
for function calls and global variable
references basically every place that
I'm about to use a function I'm about to
call a function at a null value at that
moment and sort of prior to that in the
execution of the program you're not
going to be able to change that
functions it's tight so here's an
example so here we have our Foo function
again and we have the call function
which calls into it now the first thing
that we can observe is that just before
the call to foo we have a dependence on
the representation of T and the
representation of food that is it
matters that T has an X field will be
bad if you took it away it matters what
the type of the X field is and so on so
we have a dependence on T we also have a
dependence on the type of foo you were
to change food to add a new parameter or
change the type of the old one that
would be bad so the we stick that
information in there everywhere else
there are no type dependencies that is
at points 1 and 2 there is nothing about
that function that says anything about
how I might use a type T
or how I call a particular function and
similarly after the call to food there's
no information that's there and so it's
uh actually I haven't have a slide on
that so we formalized this analysis that
was just to give you a flavor of it and
we had a papal at paper at poeple this
year that talked about it and we set it
up as a type system for a simple
imperative language called Proteus and
in this language we made update points
explicit in the program text so you
could reason about where updates might
happen and we developed an inference
algorithm that inferred those sets like
the way that I showed you before and we
proved a theorem that said that well
formed and well-timed updates will not
call it the program to go wrong and we
have a it's a very intuitive idea of
what a well-formed update is that is
basically one that comes from a program
that you could have compiled and run
from it on its own and the well timed is
defined by these these constraints sets
you won't suddenly realize that you
can't make an update that you want
that's exactly what this analysis does
so what this does is it runs over the
current version of the program and it
figures out all of the constraints that
the current version imposes on future
updates that is basically what we're
worried about is active code at the time
of an update and so we can certainly
reason about what code could be active
at each update point and therefore we
can capture those constraints the
program should be updatable event that's
right so that that's what these sets are
saying they're actually saying the
opposite they're saying you can update
anything except for tea and foo at this
point
drugs r during an update if depending
upon what its active certain update may
fail that's right these were in what
actually happens in our implementation
is it's just the way for some period of
time until it reaches an update point
where it can succeed and if after some
period of time it wouldn't work that it
would fail but the nice thing about this
analysis is because we can do it all in
advance you don't know that any way that
it will be able to look and see does
there exist an update point in my
program that allows me to do the update
that I have now crafted that I'm about
to apply so it gives us a way to do a
little bit of reasoning in advance okay
so this information that you showed here
is that global or is that just per stack
frame its squabble so okay so if I if I
were calling this call method from some
other method function that had
constraints they would be reflected that
these program points inside as well yes
okay that's correct so my question I
guess would be why why don't you
transfer the stack when you do the
update
however you that well he basically would
change the reputation of stuff that's on
the stack as well and you would update
the pc to reflect the corresponding you
oh oh I see I feel good so in some sense
that's what this this Lube abstract
extraction stuff is doing right it's
giving you a a pre compilation way of
changing the stack you could let's see I
think would be very hard to
automatically change the stacked to
satisfy these dependencies oh this is
responding to this guy but in some sense
that's exactly what this analysis is
doing for you it's saying that this this
current program point these are the
dependencies that are going to happen in
the continuation of old what I'm saying
is that suppose you have a stack frame
high up on your stack that took some
adders of some concrete stuff that you
that you don't that you want to change
well as long as that frame is up on the
stack there you can never change that
data basically that's right but I mean
how are you gonna how are you gonna make
that stack frame go away without
changing with the program thing instead
of trying to make it go away transform
the whole stack I don't know if that if
that's feasible in some way but well you
just didn't so you didn't suggest it as
one of the possible okay solutions right
I guess okay maybe I just think it's
it's too hard are you I might be too I
mean you could think of it as extreme
right suppose you see guest your program
right now everything's a function and
you know how to update entry hey
absolute stead of having your stack
right you just have infinite you know
uni-directional function calls that
don't return and you're always able to
patch that whenever that's exactly my
mistake i do that i see it's not so if
you were to do that you would have to
you would have to rely on the programmer
to provide an update to deal with the
continuation of the code that was on the
stack that you wanted to transform which
is what i was saying what we're
essentially doing with lubeck extraction
and it seems like if you want to do that
for all possible update points that's
going to be an
oh right but it does mean that anywhere
you want to create an update point you
can do the equivalent of mr. that's
correct that's correct since this
analysis needs to be conservative and
because it's
in a procedural in practice you don't
find these sets no because typically the
update points that we are interested in
so that for example the vsftpd thing I
showed you before are very shallow in
the stack and so what happens is you
have a few types that you care about
that you might care about that are
restricted but really this is not saying
that you can't update these things what
it's saying is you can't change their
types so in particular you could update
T to be a subtype you could add a bunch
of fields to it and you wouldn't break
any old code that uses the old fields
and for food you could certainly replace
the definition of food with something
else as long as you didn't change its
prototype so even with those
restrictions there doesn't necessarily
mean you can't perform an update and we
haven't we definitely have found it to
be a problem in practice this is these
are just restrictions on the changes to
important representation invariants
totally yeah yeah so for my for my
thesis I did a web server but it was
pretty small was eight thousand lines
whereas I'll tell you about the
experience that in a moment that we're
doing now where we've looked at openssh
which is about 60,000 lines in this ftp
server which grew to the point of being
about 25,000 lines and all of them tend
to have this top-down structure where
you have an event loop of some sort and
it's always feasible in our experience
so far to stick the update points in the
event loop and they're pretty available
and it's a very easy state to reason
about so that you're sure you don't
break something when you do the update
and I would think that I mean and the
nice thing is I would think the same
thing would be true with with an
operating system which is again an event
based program where you're going to have
you know essentially no stack it's going
to show up at a system call so doing
updates at points of system calls seems
like a completely feasible thing to do
and that's one of our future work things
is to work on a small OS kernel and
start to get some experience there okay
so the only thing that I'll say about
that beyond this house I'll skip past
that the two type rules I was going to
show you is that the interesting thing
about this analysis so what we do is we
set it up as something that tracks
whether or not you'd see we use
capabilities and is in the analysis what
happens is you whenever you're about to
concretely access a type not it's not
just that that type is something that
you know about in your type environment
but it's also in your current capability
and the capability can change due to an
update and that's going to be mystifying
but I don't have time to say any many
more than that but the interesting thing
is that that insight allowed us to
realize that we could apply the same
analysis to dynamically updating
security policies that is in an
information flow type system where you
track the flow of information in your
program with labels on your types you
often well you probably will want to
change your security policy for a
long-running program over time and you
have the same issue that if you change
your security policy at a bad time you
might you know release some bad
information or the fact that you've
changed the policy might release
information on its own so the same sort
of dependency analysis about what
representations I care about four types
can also be applied to security policies
in terms of is
these facts to be true at this program
point and then after this program point
I don't assume them to be sure anymore
and said it's fine for you to change
them so we've started to push in this
direction and we have a workshop paper
now that explores that idea yes it's a
well so I there there's a man well has
done some work and worrying about using
capabilities to worry about reasoning
with manual memory management where you
can think of I'm only allowed to
dereference this pointer if that pointer
is in my capability that I've been able
to track at compile time that it's sort
of a pointer I'm allowed to access and
what we're doing here is we're saying
that well it's not just pointers or
dynamic data that may or may not be in
your capability it's actually
definitions that for most programs are
just fixed for the whole lifetime of the
program but for our programs are not and
so what happens is the fact that it
needs to be in the capability and the
fact that the update might want to
change it create this tension which
results in the constraints about what
you can and can't change okay so the
other interesting thing about the
analysis is when you apply it to see you
have to worry about the ampersand
operator that is an abstruse to a type
also is a problem not just using it
concretely so in particular here when I
call this function foo i'm pointing into
t when I'm to referencing it inside of
foo so if i were to then while i'm in
food change t to be represented some
other way it might mess up what foo is
supposed to do so we have this analysis
that identifies these so-called suspect
aliases whenever you create an alias
into a type and that gets annotated on
the types themselves so that int star
with a tea after it says that well this
is a pointer into the type t and that
implies that at this point at any point
where there's a suspect alias that's
active that it's live you're not allowed
to update t and so there are no
constraints down here there are
constraints up there while the suspect
alias is active so then these two
analyses that i presented we combine
them both and these would be the
ultimate restrictions on what you could
update in this program
ok so the implementation the compiler
was implemented using sil which is a
great o camel tool from for analyzing
seed programs that was written it at
berkeley and the safety analysis we
generate constraints that are solved
with banshee which is a super fast
constraint solver the patch generation
tool is i talked about it already it's
pretty straightforward it will do a lot
of stuff for you to eliminate grunt work
but ultimately the programmer does need
to do some work with the patches and
then ultimately these patches are
compiled into shared objects which get
loaded into the program so for our
experience we've tried it out on 22
programs we've actually tried it a
little bit on Apache too but not too
much and the one we spent the most time
is this very secure ftp demon which
started out when we began updating it at
12,000 or fifteen thousand lines of code
and then over three years it changed
twelve times and grew to twenty three
thousand lines of code and then this is
some of the ways that it changed and we
were able to perform updates for all 12
of these things so we could start
version 1.1 point zero and we could
update it straight up to version 2.0
point three generating a patch for each
version while it was you know serving
lots and lots of ftp requests we also
have been started to work on openssh
demon which is a little bit bigger
program and we've so far updated 5
version changes over 11 months and
nearly as many function bodies and so on
have changed but there are fewer
prototype and type changes so this is a
visualization of the way vsftpd changed
over time so the the x-axis there is
lines of code and the sorry the y-axis
is lines of code and the x axis is time
proceeding to the right and so you can
see here that the versions as the
program grew over time and the big
changes were here here and here and the
rest of them were either smaller changes
or or bug fixes well I guess I'll talk
about a little bit up about about
particular changes for openssh this is
the way the the program worked this is
one of these odd cases where they
actually deleted a whole bunch of stuff
so we were able to update the delete
part that was easy so anyway this is as
far as we've gotten here
and we haven't gotten to any of the
major stuff yet so the way that that
this has worked is we have to choose the
program it has to choose these update
points as I've been talking about so at
the so far the way we've set it up is
that updates are only permitted at the
conclusions of the main event loops and
there are two loops in vsftpd one for
each of the sessions so when the parent
accepts a connection it Forks off a
child process which then implements the
command loop for you know downloading
files and listing directories and things
like that and the other one is in the
actual accept loop in the parent and in
openssh it's the main event loop for
accepting connections we had to make
some small changes to the applications
themselves in order to make them
updateable so there are a bunch of
places where they used some sort of
unsafe casts which they didn't really
need to which confuse the analysis so we
had to get rid of those and make it a
little cleaner and we had to relax the
application invariant in one case for
vsftpd because of updates so the
interesting thing here was in version
one point I think was the one point 2
point 0 or something like that they
added support for per IP address
connection throttling so that you what
they would do is every time you forked
off a child connection to handle an ftp
request they would map the pit of the
child into the number of current
connections associated sorry map the pit
of the child to the IP address of the
connection where it was originating and
then they had another hash table that
mapped the IP address to the number of
connections coming from that IP address
so that they could disallow too many
from the same address so we had to go
from a program that didn't have any of
this stuff to adding it and supporting
it and the problem was that in the
version that didn't have this stuff the
the signal handler didn't for a child
process dying didn't do anything but in
the new version the signal handler would
update these counts inside of the table
so every time a process died it would
look up the pit in the hash table
decrement the count and then exit and
the assumption was well of course it's
going to be in the hash table but of
course it isn't if you updated in the
middle because you had to say six
connections that were active at the time
you did the update and when the child
died there's nothing in the hash table
so we just had to add a small if check
to the signal handler that said well if
it's in the hash table do all this stuff
otherwise don't do
how did I figure it out no actually not
so well I'll say two things so first my
students were working on this update and
that happened to them it updated and it
crashed and then they and then they
figured it out so then I came in last
week and wanted to figure out what all
these things were doing so I didn't look
at any of their patches and I went
straight to the diffs between the two
versions and I saw that the signal
handler had been added and I knew right
away that we needed to add this check
and you know lo and behold they had
added the check so yeah that's that's
what I would say but I mean the nice
thing is the way that our model works is
that you're going to develop your your
updateable application offline and you
can test it all off line so that you
know if it crashes you'll you'll know
that you can work out the kinks in your
patches before you deploy it on your
online system so it's all very testable
but the nice thing is we didn't have to
relax these application invariants very
much it was it was pretty rare that in a
20,000 line program we maybe had to
change you know 25 lines of the program
to get it to work
or did you actually have to go so you
presumably you could go in one diff if
you wanted to I would think that would
be a lot harder because a lot more stuff
would have changed between those periods
of time and furthermore it wouldn't have
you know helped us test how often you
can perform these updates I mean it was
nice to be able to just say well let's
pretend that we're the user and we're
running our program and as new releases
come out we patch them so we were trying
to simulate what you would do in
practice you could certainly imagine
doing the whole thing in advance and you
could even imagine doing it the way we
did it which is to write a whole bunch
of patches and compose them and apply
them all at once we just have there's no
reason that you have to you can pick any
two versions and try to update then
that's fine
I know would make it easier GC and also
for instance track things that marked
the objects right so if you were true i
guess the GC points themselves would
make a safe of paper
because the GC would probably be keeping
a lot of bookkeeping information about
the layout layout of objects etc if you
were to do some update in between to GCS
that would potentially screw up there
geez right so that's that's true it
depends on well it's hard to imagine
though how so clearly your GC would have
to be involved if you're going to do the
type updating the way I talked about it
before so in the stuff that I did for my
thesis I had a garbage collector but I
finessed the whole that problem that
you're talking about by not allowing
types to be updated per se but rather
every time I change the type it sort of
was a new type and I had to copy all the
old values over and create new values
and then redirect the pointers and then
there's no issue with the GC so if
you're going to do the changes in place
and you have this weird union
representation with slop and so on yeah
then you're going to then you may
potentially have to work with the GC but
i don't i don't think actually would be
that hard to update the bookkeeping
information you have a question bit
assumption that there was previous state
you know the same with the path table
like that's an idiom that would be
fairly common being if you get detected
automatically or
people guide introducing state on my own
new versions because you know I can
imagine that people make an error a lot
essentially until they get used to the
back foot you know but it's an
interesting sort of frame of mind to
think you know it's like not only am I
updating a program but if there is an
instance of the program running that has
all the sumption you know in the context
of here when I update and so it's more
than just these automatic chains it's
actually sort of bin Laden you have to
change your logical think that's true
that's true so that the we the
experience I had in my thesis work with
the web server I had a similar issue
where I updated the connections too we
also added a cash and the the web server
connections a sort of precession
structure pointed to the cache entry for
this particular file that it was serving
and when you had existing connections
there wasn't anything in the cash yet so
I needed to change the logic so that
that cash pointer could be null as
opposed to always pointing to a cache
injury so I think you're probably right
that it should be not infeasible to
detect that to detect it and maybe do
something about it automatically program
head of the earth and let's say the
error was expressed as like there was an
invariant on the data structure that was
violated and so I fixed the error by
correcting the code so that invariant
wouldn't be violent anymore but then if
I did the update i would have all the
instances of the data
violated very frank so do you have to
basically write the code so they can
deal with both cases and propagate the
air into the future or repair the old
data so that it actually supports the
new invariant yeah I think so I haven't
actually I haven't ever had to do that
myself but yeah well in fact so so the
the hash table was added in this version
1 12 or something like that and then two
iterations later they added support for
ipv6 so what happened was the hash
tables originally pointed to 32-bit
addresses for ipv4 addresses and then
they got turned into 128 bit addresses
and as because of the way that these
things were done these are just aliases
to system types those types were not
updatable automatically and so we had to
write a function that would actually go
through the hash table and morph it into
a hash table that pointed to these
hundred twenty eight bit addresses
instead and then install the new table
and throw away the old one so in some
sense that's kind of like a data
structure repair
so writing type transformers most often
in in the application in the two
applications it was just adding new
fields to structs and oftentimes there
it wasn't hard to write type
transformers because the new fields were
often for optional functionality so it's
like well if you have these flags set
when you're running your program then
these extra fields mean something but
since you started your program and you
didn't have those flag set obviously
these new fields don't mean anything and
if they were to mean something they're
only going to mean something four new
connections not existing ones and so the
Transformers seem to work out pretty
well the most common transformers that
we had to write work for the extracted
loops for this state and again that was
pretty simple because most often you're
adding stuff to the code for your loop
so most of the old state was still there
and then you just at you had to allocate
space for a couple of extra local
variables and finally there there was a
need for update time initialization
maybe you added some new features that
normally would have been initialized in
Maine but obviously are not running main
anymore and so you have to update them
you have to run them at update time so
so far my take on this is that code is
pretty straightforward I mean if you
look at the across all these versions
330 functions changed and so on I mean
first a number of these patches I almost
didn't even have to look at what the
patch in I don't have to change anything
that the patch generator generated and
it's just by having the update point in
the outermost loop and having things
being acquiescence state things just
kind of take care of themselves the more
challenging part is data because this is
often times where program invariants are
going to change they're going to change
the way that data is they're going to
change when data is changes its
representation and so you have to figure
out ways to deal with that and like
figuring out about this hash table or
whatever vsftpd that was one way in
which it was non-trivial to do the
update we had to write this thing to
convert the hash table from the old
representation to the new representation
but I mean even that it actually still
wasn't all that hard I mean once as long
as you understand the code that's
changing and presumably if you're the
developer of this product you understand
your product then you're able to look at
it and and write the update that perhaps
the counterpoint to what I just said is
that this is this may not be true for
very large systems right there's no one
person that understands all of Windows
I'm sure
right it's only what 50 million lines of
code so it's hard to tell when changes
are localized it would be really nice to
be able to say that well changes to this
file have nothing to do with all the
changes over here so if I understand
what's going on here I don't need to
worry about what's happening in the rest
of my application and this certainly
happened so in the signal handler
example that I told you about the fact
that I change the signal handler over
here affected the fact that I added this
code to do this hash table stuff over
here and I need to know that these two
changes were related I couldn't look at
them independently so so far we've just
been looking at all of the changes
understanding what the program does and
then writing the patch based on the
result but it would certainly be nice to
be able to more modularly reason about
these changes in your program so that
you can look at independent parts and
deal with them independently so
performances is basically reasonable for
for these service style applications
which are largely i/o bound that is it's
going to come from function and
directions and from type wrapping and
there's going to certainly be
performance overhead for both the
running time in the memory footprint and
we measured performance overhead by
looking at application throughput for
the two applications so either request
for a second or for transfer rate and we
also ran another micro benchmark
application so to speak for measuring
the cost of type wrapping because none
of these server applications used types
in a very intensive way so the summary
is that the application performance was
basically unchanged there was at most
two percent overhead on throughput and
there was at most thirty-one percent
memory footprint overhead so not a
problem and the micro benchmark found
that type wrapping can impose a more
significant overhead so we saw as much
as a hundred percent overhead for type
wrapping and I was basically because of
cash locality issues so that further
motivates our wanting to explore other
options
only selected points in the code
execution which probably means that you
don't have to keep an overhead for extra
space for all the
occupation
definitely so we've already thought of
them well we haven't thought of all the
ones that necessarily you're thinking it
but we've thought of some that is just
as you say if I'm only going to perform
an updates they have this big call tree
of the possible my program that's
possible in my program and have the
update point up here I don't need to
have levels of indirection for all of
the functions that are down here I only
need to worry about the ones that are up
here so the only thing that makes that
question interesting is that being able
to throw away old versions when you
update them that is to unload them and
what you would like to do is minimize
the amount of unloading that you have to
do so we've developed an algorithm that
allows you to group together as many
functions as possible into a single
shared object since they're likely to be
to live and die together or to be to be
related so that if you were to change
one you were likely to change other ones
and therefore they can be loaded and
unloaded in a group but certainly the
question of well if an update happens
here and I only ever call these
functions following the update those are
the only places i need to add an
interaction that's that's a
straightforward optimization no we
didn't do it this is this is with all of
the overhead of the syllable I don't
know possibly
we're going to try it out too I'll let
you know try to balance I on cpu they
basically want the CPU peg and so they
have enough disks and things like that
do you have any sense of with overhead
would be in a system like that you know
where the CPU is really peg basically so
that so the so this is the overhead for
that basically if we were to use the
stock system for this fast fourier
transform this is our current
implementation of the type wrapping
basically the we're really stupid about
where we insert cons for the accessor
functions we have this extra slop which
is which blows away the cash locality
and both of these things together make
it you know more than a factor of two
worse if we instead don't we reduce the
amount of slop that is we make it so
that there's zero slop there's just a
version field and we're smarter about
the cons then this is the overhead of
the whole program so this is saying that
there's you know fifty percent overhead
perhaps for your scenario so it could be
that the optimizations for function in
directions and everything else would
start to chip away at this but for the
i/o bound stuff so far we just haven't
found it to be a big deal the maximum
optimization the compounded maybe even
sure the maximum edition you saw some
interesting things with you we we we use
GCC 34 and we compiled everything with
03 we didn't do 06 or something like
that if you do was a student some people
too well when we did without 6 the
program would chord up right away when
you started running
without them for that the changes it
with with our compiler okay I mean when
we would transform it but not when we
did an update or anything like that just
didn't work so varied optimization
making things in your wallet so that so
certainly the cash locality is hurting
you with type wrapping the interactions
are hurting you that is for photo frame
Army National Guard is well I'm claiming
that there's bugs in GCC that since
since GCC's 06 is almost never used and
certainly not on gigantic programs then
there's bugs in it I mean I see this all
the time whenever I try to crank up
optimization in GCC it just doesn't work
so closely spaced on hello no no not I'm
all broken something I think perhaps
different public optimizing away
your update points like for example the
function and direction do you have a
problem with it in lining that where you
don't want it to we haven't had that
problem because he's
we haven't had that problem but i'm not
sure why we have an end that's a good
question flickr within live love this
well i was going to say that that's
actually part of the issue with the the
functioning direction that when you add
a function in direction with every
function you kill all possibility of
inlining so that's why the optimization
that we were just talking about would
probably be helpful if you've been
learning really matter which it
presumably does in this application
wondering you know there's been a lot of
work in the manage language space like
Jabba optimizers were they doing things
like you optimize and then someone does
a kinetic class load and you have to
clean up and recover state and all that
kind of stuff that feels a lot like this
yeah definitely so that so I I was at a
workshop work on virtual execution
environments and people were telling me
about stuff they were doing with on
stack replacement and things like that
and it definitely has a similar flavor I
mean the advantage that they have is
that semantics of the function didn't
change just the representations change
and so that makes the problem a little
bit more automatical if you will whereas
here it you know like the thing you were
talking about man well it seems like you
really need programmer intervention to
be able to say that well if this stuff
is on the stack and I do the update here
you need to tell me what I'm supposed to
do with this modified stack thing but
maybe not maybe there's school ways to
automate it I don't know seems hard
assembly did the actual code that was
only for this for the function pointers
that's not for the regular calls inside
of the you know the extracted function
that was just that was just the the
function wrapper that then calls through
the in direction is a jump the function
wrapper is basically a little jump
whereas if you were to call the function
directly that is through a level of
indirection in the data space so that
the a milliner you know the ascent it
could it could change it maybe it's
because it's a global variable and it's
non-local that it chooses not to inline
it because it thinks that it could
change later on I don't know why did it
a study wasn't polanco member pediment
for other programs what I mean what is
SSD doing which is making the orbit
higher so it depends somewhat on how
many functions you have so if you had
one big function as opposed to 50 little
functions you're going to introduce a
little bit of extra space for those same
thing goes with the number of types that
you have right so you have this type
rapping thing that's going to add some
slop you have a whole bunch of instances
of a particular type that's going to
blow up your space overhead as opposed
to just one or two instances of a few
types and so for vsftpd thirteen-percent
basically the types that we're
updateable there were only a couple of
them there was the session object and
things like that so it added very little
overhead whereas for ssh there were many
more obtainable objects most of the
times also memory is basically an array
or a buffer or something and that is
what takes the maximum space
and so nice to see a 30-percent or
thirty one percent number because when i
write a program i don't think i think we
better take that model one you can
discuss your program two styles and you
have to resume
Michael finished oh okay well thank you
for all the questions so there's there
is has been a bunch of related work in
this general area of updating software
dynamically I think the most active
project right now is the K 42 project at
IBM which they're pursuing how to
upgrade their research operating system
the k42 operating system and they have
made some progress there Erlang is a
functional language that was developed
at ericsson that has specific language
primitives for performing dynamic
updates in the language their domain is
a little bit simpler because it's a
purely functional language and they have
comparatively less analysis they rely
much more on the programmer sort of
doing the right thing and less on help
from automatic tools and there have been
a various other proposals to do this
sort of thing but very little
implementation experience has been
published although of course you know
but the phone company and and folks like
that have been doing this stuff for a
long time as far as the safety analysis
goes there have been a number of people
that will look at some form of safety
analysis for dynamic updating so I've
lifted listed a few here I list this
paper at the bottom the capability
language which is what I was talking
about as the foundation of the analysis
that we do that was applied to manual
memory management or region based memory
management but we use the same sort of
principles and the analysis that we did
so basically what we're doing right now
is continuing to push on trying it out
with applications we want to find out
where this technique falls down what are
the the serious hurdles to getting it to
work in practice we've we've made a lot
of progress so far but we ultimately
want to work toward you know can we
update some kernel can we make it so
that you get a security patch and you
can just patch your kernel and move on
and you don't need to reboot it every
time to do this I think we're going to
need to do a lot more automation we're
going to have to fix this slop based
type updating it would be nice to be
able to prove some additional properties
about your program so we talked about
the modularity issue before it would be
cool if you could take advantage of
traits of your program to simplify the
process of updating it which I think you
probably can and we also don't currently
handle multiple threads although I know
at least an easy way to do it the
interesting thing is to develop a more
sophisticated analysis that's better
than the easy way and we've talked a lot
about optimization
so my conclusion is that I believe that
dynamic software updating that this
technique can be practical we've made a
lot of progress towards updating actual
programs we found that in general these
things are fairly straightforward and
that performance overhead is is not even
so bad without performing any serious
optimizations and i think that the next
step to making it scale up is to really
continue to push on stronger reasoning
techniques so that you can look at your
updates in a more modular way and so
that if you know i make some local
change to some big program i don't have
to worry about my change dynamically
during the update impacting some other
part of the program so we'll see how
that goes thanks for your tension there
more questions please see Michael
upfront and thanks again for coming
you